now the eight news now i-team has been
working to figure out how this crash
happened and whether there were safety
issues that could have addressed prior
to that deadly accident the i-team's
vanessa murphy has more
nevada state police are investigating
whether this beam was secured before the
impact from the truck the beam is put in
place to warn larger vehicles about the
bridge up ahead normally if a truck hits
the beam it would be damaged but it's
not supposed to collapse sources say the
company doing the construction at the
site of the beam for the centennial bowl
project is las vegas paving i called
them twice today and was told since the
incident is still under investigation
they have no comment we looked into las
vegas paving on osha's website at least
six violations are listed since 2017.
most of these are still considered open
investigations because they're being
contested one is in connection with a
worker's death last year at least four
others in connection with bridge
construction the most recent
investigation involved the bridge
collapse last january near the 95 and
eastern however the case is closed and
no violations were issued for that one
as for the truck that hit the beam we've
learned it's owned by western states
contracting that north las vegas-based
company also declined to comment osha's
website lists at least four violations
for them since 2017 including a 48
thousand dollar fine there was also an
investigation after an employee was
injured on the job and lost a finger a
spokesperson for the nevada department
of transportation says its permitting
office is currently investigating
whether the truck had the proper permit
by law oversized vehicles like this must
have a permit from ndot to travel on
highways an ndot spokesperson also says
this early warning beam at the center of
this accident is the only one currently
in use in southern nevada reporting in
the newsroom vanessa murphy live local
now